pou dou dou
ようこそ会津若松にお越しくださいました
私長谷川順一
人呼んでハセジュンと言われます
この合図はこのと一番よく知ってそして会津を伝えようとする
1弱小農家の一人です
そして皆さんにはおそらくふるさとの味
お母さんはじっそういったものが一人一人違うと一緒で作られている作物もその土地
その土地で
特徴のある作物があったはずです
私
農業をやる前に実はあのスポーツ選手なろう
スポーツの体育教師になろうなんていう夢も持っていました
実は
今から二十し5年前親父が他界しまして
で農業ということに
目を向ける機会をいただきましたその中で
俺の農業って何だろう
何ができるんだろう
すごく悩みながら大人の指導を受けながら農業を続けてきました
その中で私の住んでいる門前町という小さな町がう
実は大変なたね思ってたんです
それがたったこれだけの
で
私あの農業を始めてふるさとの味をもう1回なんか復活させたらいいんじゃないかと
いうことで
そういった野菜たちを育てることを
決意して
そして sp スピーカーになりながらみんなに伝えていこうっていう強い信念をもっ
て始めました
そのなかの1つ
これは何でしょう
きゅうり休館そうですこれは今見るキュウリなんです
これはみなさんの食卓に常に登ったりするキュウリの一つなんですけどそれではもう一
つ
どうでしょう
色が違いますよね
実はこのきゅうりは3000年前にさかのぼります
それは中東のとこから人が歩き
人が育って繋いできて日本に入ってきます
そういった大切な大切なひとつの金なんですん
そして
私が作り始めて
市場に出すと1本もれないです
なんでだろうどうして食べれないのかなみんなと思ったらやっぱり見た目
資格色
それが
目から入って頭の中で植え付けられてこれがきゅうりという
一つの答えが出てるんです
こちらキュウリを選択する余地が頭の中にないんでしょうね
そして
場所このキュウリを大切に守りたい
7年7名の生産者でスタートしたこのキュウリなんですけど売れないからみんなやめ
ちゃいました
そしてたった一人私だけになってしまいました
もちろん周りの農家さんからは
そんな売れないキュウリ作ってどうするんだ
誰がそんなける買うんだそんな抜針をいっぱい浴びました
そして1件1件市内の飲食店をあるって
一人一人に食べていただいてその中から1件2件3件と増えてきました
使いたい使ってあげたいとっていう答えをいただきました
そしてもう一つ
誰に伝えればいいのかなと思ったときに子どもたちです
私が一番最初に行なったのは学校給食という
そちらに提供することを決意しましたそして
栄養士戦えー士の先生方からも
これがキュウリ何ですか家扱いたくないな
最初そういう言葉ばっかりですところが初めて使った学校給食のがっこう傘
生徒さんが
どうしてもキュウリが嫌いだ
きゅうり嫌いな子がそんなに多いですかって言ったら結構今の若い子たちが多いんです
よ
わかりましたじゃあぜひこのキュウリ食べてもらってください
学校給食もあって
昼休み先生がすぐ電話くれました長谷川さん
あれだけ嫌いの子が食べてくれた
美味しい美味しいと言ってくれた
あーこれなんだ
スモークオール私は嬉しくなって
よしこれから絶対これを広めていこう
そんな決意もその時に感じさせますね
それが
勢いがどんど
ましていく中で
自分だけのものじゃないんだこれを
日本のもの故郷のものそれ
一人一人のものなんだ
っていうことを感じまして
それが震災後
原発事故が起きて
何も作れないような状態ここから立ち上がるっていうのがどういったことなのかといっ
たときにその命なんですね
金の命これを広めなきゃなんないと思いまして
地元にある会津農林高校という農業高校の生徒さんたちがぜひやってみたいというお話
をいただきました本当にうれしくて人も
安住泣いていました
そんな種の話なんですけど
実際今現在合図にはこのような中発種類の
数々の
伝統野菜ございます
それ一つ一つが何百年も何千年も人形音をつないでいまだに残っているそんな大切な命
なんですよね
これを今
会津農林高校と一緒にシード bank 的な存在にしようということで高校があり
続ける限りこの種は絶えない
そんなものにしようということで活動させていただいております
その中でもう一つ大切にしたいもの野菜のためそれ以外じゃなくてそればかりじゃなく
て
会津能書というこれは江戸時代の中期に書かれた
能楽所です
でこの脳がそ農楽舎全国に数々ある能楽師の中で一番
科学的な根拠をもとに
人々に伝えたと言われている
教科書です
でこの中にはその当時この伝統野菜も含め
育てた経緯どんな土地に作ればいいかどんな時期に巻けばいいかそれを細かく研究され
て
農民一人一人に伝えたとされております
ぜ左に見える能書っていうのがあるんですけど
これも農民たち当時は読み書きもできなかった
そんな時代なので絵によって地帯を
それから号7号のは彼に
その時その時の作業の内容を伝えようっ
そういった分かりやすく
江戸時代に書かれた本なんですでこの中でも
素晴らしいと思ったのは
疲労農薬っていうのは実は戦後七十年なんです日本で広まってもらう
この当時は何もありません
この時に一番大切したのは実は皆さん
この会場にいる酒の粕なんです
酒勝つというのは乳酸発酵を興してそして
水溶性炭水化物
そういった物質になります実はその中にはクエン酸だったり
オリゴ糖だったり本当に一人一人の体にすごく大切な栄養そう
産んでくれます
それが作物で一番の栄養なんですよ
それを宿時代に磨いてたもんなんですねでこれを利用して今現在に
作れるものはないかということを今井着々と仲間と一緒に育てておりますそれが
いわゆる
世界でいうオーガニックにつながるんじゃないかな
そして
私の行っている事業というのは高校生だけじゃなくて小さい子どもたちにも
伝えていこうふるさとの味をつくっていこう
そして戻るアジン氏を支えてきたや事象ということで今現在
市内の高校中学小学校幼稚園
それぞれで
こういった伝統野菜をつくっていただいて自分たちの作った野菜も
学校給食で使ってもらってそれを見る
後輩たちがな来年そのタネを使う
で先輩たちはそのタネをとって
次の年につなぐ
そういった活動の中で子どもたちの笑顔っています本当に食べることによくと笑顔が
増えた
そんな授業の一つです
これは小学校での授業風景なんですけど
実際私はこの場で指導したことはほとんどありません
実はその
青いポロシャツを着ている高校生たちが小学生に対して授業を行っています
またの幼稚園そんなところでも授業を行うんですけどじゃあ幼虫にわかりやすく
銅や鉄作用といった時に紙芝居を作ってくれました
これは高校生だからできる若いからで若い子だからできるアイディアの一つだと思い
ます
でこれは実際高校生に私が授業として栽培の方法を教えたり
ここを気をつけましょう
でも自然自然にできる野菜は本当に地下力が強いから諦めないで頑張れをそんな事業を
年間後6回ほど
やらせていただきまして
自信を持ってこの子たちが今世の中に表目用としております
で私は
次の世代もこの高校生たちが
会津のスターになって欲しいと思っていろんなところに方向性を連れていって自分たち
の思いというのを伝えることで
自信を持つそういった野菜たちになるそう願っております
さてもう一つ
福島県には原発志向がありました私も残念ながら避難先になった会津若松なんですけど
そこの避難所に当時とれていた野菜をすべて
提供しましたところが県内のある一箇所
放射能を検出された途端すべての生産を停止
残念ながらその避難された方々には野菜というミネラルを与えることができなかったん
です
しかし先月私も講演がありまして
原発に入らせていただきましたこれがその時の映像なんですけど
実は
見える数字20マイクロシーベルト
これは今現在の
燃料プールにあった4号機の目の前の数値です
ご覧のように
社員それから
さあ従業員方々の努力の結果
ここまで下がることができましたそれで敷地内は全て
0.8マイクロシーベルト
私たちこうやって生活しているブルーとほとんど変わりません
そのくらい作業環境が整ってスピーディーに今原発の内での作業は進んでおります
こういった人たちの努力それから我々の農業者生産者
そういった仲間というのが今の福島には
すごいパワーとなって動き始めると思います
そしてもう一つ
pump
これはカボチャです皆さん食べた方もいらっしゃると思うんですが実はこれ
400年ほど前に日本に初めて入ったかぼちゃの一つ
実は伝えたのはポルトガル人です
そして当時冬期間栄養あの高い作物がないということで
全国の版2個の種を伝え
全国て作られたかぼちゃなんです
実際今は f 1死といって一代交配の野菜たちが身の回りを埋め尽くされてこういっ
た際来週てのほとんど目につくことができません
実際私腹鳴
始めたのはたった2件
会津の中でも残った農家2軒しかありませんでした
来れば
食べてみるとわかります
甘くないん
自然な甘みなんです
その自然な甘みというのは生命の力強さなんです
ってこういった野菜たちを広めようとして今現在高校生たち
それから
日本国内の
気持ちのある農家さんそれからいろんな方々によって
種が繋がれております今現在会津若松でも
20軒ほどの農家が取り組むようになりました
そして作りながら大切にするふるさとの味にする
そういった生産者が今現在増え続けております
そして
なんとこのある雑誌に私を取り上げていただいた結果私をスペインに連れて行って頂き
ました
でポルトガルに里帰りをさせたいこの種を誘われちゃったいと思いから
隣の国スペインが動いてくれて
そしてスペインで[ __ ]の小学生たちと一緒に種をまいて
福島のこと会津のことを伝えてきました
そんなことを今スペインと一緒に色々な活動を通して
世界中食でつながるんだなっていうのを
教育の中から少し変えていけないかということで現在
スペイン政府から
尾羽がありまして
きょうかしょん4を
いう話に曲がっておりますそして
このため実は原産国どこでしょうカボチャの計三国
人いますか
知らないですよね
昔私先生に習ったのは
カンボジアから来たからかぼちゃ
聞いたことあると思います
しかしそれは pot ポルトガル戦績がカンボジアを経由して日本でナンパしたから
カボチャっていう話になったかぼちゃっていうのは in 道ではあっ
そしてカープカンボジアでは
なんだそれという言葉だらしいんです見たことがない
だからそれを日本人はかぼちゃかぼちゃと見たことない見たことないって言うことを
信じ付付けて今まあ今もカボチャと呼んでいる
そしてそのポルトガルが実はそのににを積んだとっていうのがエクアドル
実は南米
が原産国なんですそして去年
ニュースが私のところに飛び込んできまして実はスペイン昔あの
南米の方を植民地として使った
そういった歴史の中でつながりがあって
エクアドルの農業者の会長が訪れた時に
この3クガット市の小学生の話を聞いてぜひウチの国でも伝えたい
日本のことを支えたいということでやっと
本当の故郷
に入りました
で世界というのは日本の野菜もそうですけど
世界って人が何日も何日もかけて
国をまたいで
それで伝えた
そういった文化が世界中あるはずです
私はこのためのつながりというのを元に世界に向けて一緒になって食そして平和って
いうのをみんなと一緒に伝えていければなと思っています
そして今現在福島県内の若い農業者が集まってチームプライド福島
こういった組織も生まれて福島のファンクラブを
生産者のファンクラブを作ろうという
頑張れる子どもたち
それから将来の子どもたちにつなげようという半ばが生まれました
福島県って広すぎて浜田変えず3つにエリアに分かれますけど
この3つがあっ
力強く生きようとしたときにたぶん世界中どこにも真似できない力が生まれると思い
ます
こういった若い生産者それから次の世代につなぐ大切な大切な金っていうのは我々大人
の仕事なんじゃないかなと思います
これから皆さん故郷に支えられてそしてそれぞれの国に帰られたときに自分の味
プル里の味もう一度考えていただければ
幸いだと思います最後に
今までの私の仲間たちをスライドで観ていただいて私の話は合う
me
rar
うん
ん
whoopee
me
ん
はいみなさん幸せな食卓を皆さんで育てていきましょう
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]